ein kleid das für jeden betrachter
anders aussieht das beste versteck für
eine zombie apokalypse und der
endgültige beweis für den
menschengemachten klimawandel all das
und noch mehr
das sind die spannenden themen jetzt in
den kriegs fox news
herzlich willkommen aus dem schlosspark
des nymphenburger schlosses hier in
münchen mysteriöses kleid sieht für
jeden anders aus am donnerstag kostete
eine frau auf tumblr dieses bild von
ihrem kleid sie wollte ihre freundin
nach meinungen zum aussehen des kleides
fragen an
stattdessen entbrannte aber schnell eine
hitzige diskussion welche farbe hat das
kleid während manche menschen ein blaues
kleid mit schwarzen streifen sehen sieht
das kleid für andere wiederum weiß mit
goldenen streifen aus innerhalb von
wenigen stunden wurde der hashtag wird
rest zum nummer eins thema weltweit
sogar viele promis mischten sich in die
diskussion ein
wenn er mir nicht glaubt weil das kleid
ganz klar und eindeutig diese oder jene
farbe hat dann schaut einfach mal unten
in die kommentare
wo jeder schwört eine andere farbe zu
sehen aber wer hat denn nun recht klar
ist das kleid ist in echt schwarz und
blau
wenn man den statistiken mancher website
aber glauben schenkt dann sieht über die
hälfte der internetnutzer ein weißes
kleid wie kann das sein nun das foto der
tumbler nutzerin wurde bei sehr
schlechten lichtverhältnissen
aufgenommen und das führt zu zwei
verschiedenen effekten im bild zum einen
liegen die beiden farben des kleides
jeweils in einer art zwischenbereich die
dunkle farbe so zeigt uns photoshop ist
ein sehr dunkles gelb braun die hellere
farbe ein graublau der zweite effekt
verursacht nun diesen spannenden effekt
das gehirn interpretiert alles was
unsere augen sehen und verändert es in
den allermeisten fällen führt das dazu
dass wir besser sehen können nur bei
optischen illusionen fällt auf dass
dieses system auch macken haben kann in
dem fall des kleides ist es die
lichtquelle die gehirne mancher menschen
gehen von einer lichtquelle links im
bild aus die der anderen aus dem
hintergrund das führt zur farbkorrektur
auf das kleid und die inzwischen farben
in schönes deutliches weißgold oder in
schwarz blau wird das eben verwandelt
was seht ihr auf dem foto schreibt es
unten in den kommentaren man sehen
welche farbe
läufer gesehen wird menschengemachte
klimawandel endlich bewiesen
zum ersten mal konnten wissenschaftler
den zusammenhang des weltweit steigenden
co2 levels und der menge an sonnenlicht
dass unsere erde trifft feststellen
über zehn jahre lang haben die forscher
die werte in alaska und oklahoma
miteinander verglichen mit dem bericht
der mittwoch im fachmagazin science
erschien ist nun endlich der geforderte
beweis für den menschengemachten
klimawandel liefert eine erhöhung von 22
co2 teilchen pro eine million teilchen
führt laut der wissenschaftler zu 0,2
watt mehr sonnenenergie pro quadratmeter
das ist ein anstieg von etwa 10% und
deckt sich mit den vorhersagen die immer
wieder in simulationen benutzt worden
die studie beweist was viele schon lange
wussten wir müssen handeln und den
klimawandel aufhalten bevor wir ein
system verändern dass wir nicht
verstehen
bestes versteckt für zombie apokalypse
ein forscher team der cornell
universität hat eine umfassende
situation einer zombie apokalypse
durchgeführt und dabei herausgefunden wo
man sich am besten verstecken sollte
wenn die ersten zombies auftauchen
die wissenschaftler haben sich bei der
studie an vorhandenen simulationen
orientiert die zum beispiel den ausbruch
von krankheiten wie ebola simulieren
dann wurden parameter für das verhalten
der untoten hinzugefügt zum beispiel
dass menschen durch ein bis infiziert
werden mit einer differentialgleichungen
einem gitter modell und der
bevölkerungsdichte wurde dann die
simulation gestartet das ergebnis die
sich gleich viele von euch denken können
übertreiben hollywood filme gerne mal
auch wenn die anzahl der zombies in den
städten sehr groß wäre
so würden auf dem land wesentlich
weniger von ihnen rumlaufen
es gibt einfach zu wenig essen weil die
bevölkerungsdichte auf dem land geringer
ist
das sicherste versteckt wäre laut der
forscher ein gebirge
dort kommen die tollpatschigen untoten
schlecht hoch und menschen gibt es dort
auch kommt dem gehirn auf der spur
das team um den forscher debra silva
geht dem menschlichen gehirn auf den
grund wie so sind wir menschen so viel
intelligenter als schimpansen
obwohl wir doch beinahe ein identisches
gehirn haben um diese frage zu
beantworten untersuchten sie die gene
der menschen und der schimpansen genauer
dabei fanden sie eine art steuer element
welches beeinflusst wie oft ein gen
abgelesen wird das gehen wurde
kurzerhand haares getauft und in
diversen mäusen eingepflanzt das
ergebnis war erstaunlich
die gehirne der mäuse mit dem
menschlichen haares gehen wurden 12
prozent größer als die der schimpansen
vor wachstum besonders betroffen war vor
allem der neokortex dieser ist für
unsere sprache und das logische denken
verantwortlich das wissenschaftlerteam
ist aber laut eigener aussage noch ganz
am anfang
sie wollen die hintergründe ihrer
entdeckung in den nächsten jahren noch
viel genauer untersuchen
die ganze schwarzes loch entdeckt
wissenschaftler aus peking und london
haben ein super massereiches schwarzes
loch im herzen einer aktiven galaxie
entdeckt laut der wissenschaftler hat es
die zwölf milliarden fache masse unserer
sonne interessant ist besonders sein
ursprung das schwarze loch ist 12 8
milliarden lichtjahre entfernt das heißt
dass das licht das uns erreicht seit 12
8 milliarden jahren zu uns unterwegs ist
zu diesem zeitpunkt den wir jetzt gerade
beobachten können war das universum noch
sehr jugend gerade einmal 900 millionen
jahre nach dem urknall hat sich bereits
ein solch gigantisches schwarzes loch
gebildet die forscher können sich das
nicht erklären denn unsere bisherigen
theorien über schwarze löcher besagen
eigentlich dass ein so schnelles
wachstum nicht möglich ist interessant
auch die materie um das schwarze loch
herum diese leuchtet sehr stark auch
bevor sie eingezogen wird deswegen
können wir das schwarze loch überhaupt
sehen allerdings sollte die energie der
strahlung die
materie die noch etwas weiter entfernt
ist wegdrücken
der sogenannte strahlungsdruck führt
normalerweise dazu dass der sog nach
zehn bis 100 millionen jahren
ausgebremst wird das ist aber noch nicht
passiert wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt was
ein schwarzes loch eigentlich ist und
was es macht dann dann kommt ihr
antworten in diesem video schwarze
löcher und ihr dunkles geheimnis alle
links zu den angesprochenen themen
findet ihr wie immer in der video
beschreibung und zur app und zum blog
geht es hier unten
und jetzt bin ich auf eure ideen
gespannt wie würdet ihr euch bei einer
zombie apokalypse stecken und welche
waffen würdet ihr mit mir diskutiert ist
wie immer mit mir den kommentaren
bist du bist an bleibt dran